The Joe Rogan experience. You know,
I've gotten a bunch of messages since that film came out from other Olympic
athletes. And, um, it's been either a mix of like, Hey man, um,
thank you so much. Or it's just like, not mad at me, just like,
what the? And then, you know, like, like,
and I was actually like, uh, invited, um, it was the, uh,
uh, the bobsled team, uh,
that when they actually disqualified the Russian bobsled team and, uh,
uh, the U S bobsled team was then going to get the third place metal.
They like invited me to the ceremony. I didn't go, but you know,
it was a crazy.
Well, Jordan said that the, uh,
guess in 2020 and 2024,
the Russians can't fly a flag. Like they, they cannot read,
they can't be represented.
Like they have to be individual athletes from Russia at,
at the Olympics in 2020 and, uh, Tokyo it's 20, 21 now,
and then 20, 24th, those Olympics,
you can't have a Russian flag.
Like you literally can't because of what happened that you exposed in your
documentary.
That's that's true. However, um, if you, if you follow the,
the story post stickers with Richard Bankoff is, um,
Russia was supposed to turn over this limbs data,
which was this laboratory information management system data, um,
in order to be reinstated into, into world sport, um,
that was part of the water requirements. And, um,
they never basically, uh, turned it over.
So water basically had to go after them, go after them, go after them.
They reinstate them without turning over the data. Then they turn over the data.
This is now, uh, December of 2019,
uh, or January. It was not that long ago, about a year ago.
And when they turn over the data,
they had literally manipulated all the data and they had already got a copy of
it from [inaudible] and another guy in the lab.
And they literally put notes into this lens data,
basically trying to frame a chain called for like money laundering and taking
bribes and all this.
But water knew that this wasn't legitimate because they had the real
databases already. So they go and they say, okay,
now Russia's banned for another four years. Right? Wow.
And in the meantime,
Russia is putting out in the media that [inaudible] has tried to commit suicide
because of like the exposure that he was apparently, you know,
taking bribes from money, which he wasn't Russia denies it again.
And then it goes to the court of arbitration for sport.
This is literally just like a couple months ago.
So they were supposed to be facing another four year total ban.
Like that's what water was recommending.
Like the entire Federation is gone and the court of arbitration for sport,
which is corrupt as hell,
basically knocks it down to two years instead of four years.
And then basically does what they did in the 2018 Olympics, which is okay,
any Russian athlete who hasn't tested positive can compete,
but they can't compete under their country's flag. But if you saw Icarus,
how would you know whether or not they were positive or not?
Because they were swapping out the urine, they were breaking into the bottles.
So it's, uh, it's like, yeah, they're kind of banned. And at the same time,
they're all going to be there.
And this was looked at it like a huge win for Russia. In the meantime,
[inaudible] literally sits in isolation in hiding under
protection. Um, but the guy just got asylum.
So I'm here, right? He got asylum. You.
Don't have to wear the headphones if you don't want it, are they uncomfortable?
No, they just kind of were like echoing a lot.
If there's a way to maybe take down the reverb on them or something, I like him.
Echoing really? Do you hear echo echo? There's a volume control. Is that better?
Yeah, that's better. Um, so [inaudible] has got asylum here in America.
Yeah. So he's got asylum here in America and that story
is crazy too. So, you know, uh,
in Icarus you see this scene where basically, like I see 'em off, uh,
at the airport and that was July of 2016.
So we keep, you know, making the film, the film comes out August,
2017 and then five months later, essentially because of the film,
the IOC, and the reason decision, uh,
comes forward and bans Russia. Uh, and they cite Icarus,
uh, as one of their, their main reasons for doing that in the meantime,
Richie Bankov is literally trying to get political asylum.
And on the day of his asylum hearing,
this was now a year and a half, two years ago.
Um, I need to get with his lawyers to get the exact date,
Russia files,
drug trafficking charges against him in Russia on the actual
day that he supposed to go in for his asylum hearing.
So what this means is that Russia had a mole within
the us immigration system,
knowing that this was the day that [inaudible] was supposed to get his as his
asylum and under international law,
anybody who's been charged with drug trafficking right,
is basically immediately ineligible for asylum.
So there's like a couple of like, you know,
things that you can be charged for that basically makes it,
you can't get asylum.
So they charge him with drug trafficking and the court then gets kicked
out and it takes them another year and a half, two years to get his asylum.
And he finally just got his asylum like four, four months ago,
something like that. Wow.
Crazy. And so, but he's still in hiding, right?
Cause he's got to worry about being assassinated. Oh yeah.
I mean, he's, he's still in hiding. I mean, I've,
I've been able to keep in touch with a guy here and there through like basically
through the lawyers and then they'll arrange through the security and then
we'll, you know, find an encrypted way to like have a conversation. And,
and, um,
last time I spoke to him was about two months ago and you know,
the conversation always goes like, uh, Hey Gregory, how are you? And he goes,
uh, I'm alive. I go, ah,
that's great. You know, but he goes, I'm like, so how are you doing? It's like,
but I, and I, and I have to tell you, he's like, you know, you saved my life.
And, uh, uh, I mean, it's, uh, it's,
it's heavy. It's really heavy. I mean, we've,
we've tried for three years now to try to get him a dog
because, you know, he loves dogs and he lives by himself and, you know,
really doesn't have communication with the outside world. Um,
my understanding is that he'll go out, you know, for like an hour,
a day for a walk, with like protection around him. Um,
I don't know where he lives. I don't, I don't have his phone number. Um,
but his security, you know,
doesn't want him to have a dog because if he has a dog,
that means he has to go outside and he's got to walk the dog.
Um, he's not really able to communicate with his family. Um,
hasn't seen his family for four years now. Uh,
his wife and his kids are back in Russia. Um, so I mean, this has been a,
this has been a crazy cost for, for blowing the whistle.
And they take his wife and his children. Didn't didn't they take their family,
their family HomeAway.
Well, after he, uh,
after he got here and then all this started to unfold, um,
what I was told is that they basically like froze the assets,
um, of the family. He had a dacha, which is like, um, a summer home.
And apparently they, uh, uh,
they seized that and they seized bank accounts.
Um, and they brought in the family to interrogate them and they, uh,
they took their passports. Um, from what I've heard,
um, is that, uh,
his kids have their passports back, uh,
and the wife does too, but, you know,
you can make the logical conclusion that they're hoping that
they travel because of that income travel and they then go
and see the Gregory, right. They're going to be able to find them.
Um, but you know, to my knowledge, um,
the family has been pretty much left alone. It was,
it was bad for a little bit. Um, but over the last few years,
um, I've heard that, you know, that, that they're okay. And, you know,
none of the, none of the family wants to wants to,
to come because even if they do,
then that means that their lives are now in isolation, in hiding.
So, uh, for them to come and basically, you know,
visit Gregory or to come and, and move, you know,
to be with him because he could technically get his wife here now that he has
asylum,
but then her life is going to be an isolation
and she's got family back in Russia. So it's, it's, uh, it's complicated.
And this goes on for the rest of his life.
Well, I mean, arguably for the rest of his life, I mean, when you look at,
you know, uh, Michael charrettes of, uh,
of the New York times did a story. I don't remember.
It's probably about a year ago. And he was looking at all these kinds of like,
um, murders that, that were, um,
tied to Putin and Russia. And one of the stories that he came out with,
um, was basically this guy who was living in the Ukraine,
he was working for the gas company. Right. And he,
uh, uh, I can't remember if he, it was an attempted murder or a no,
the guy gets killed and they catch the guy, the assassin, uh,
who goes to kill him. And they pulled him up on trial.
And when they catch this assassin,
apparently he's got him a piece of paper on him. It's got a list of names,
right. Of like, basically like, you know,
like a kill names and this guy who they arrest.
And I know I'm botching the story a little bit and you can go back. It was, uh,
uh, was in, you know, part of the New York times daily. And, um,
and this guy that they go and arrest, um,
basically goes, yes, I I've been hired. I don't know why, but, you know,
my job is basically to, to kill these people.
So they start going through the list and none of these people are really
known. It turns out that the guy that he had been hired to kill him,
the Ukraine who was now living like a normal life in the Ukraine,
he had apparently helped broker weapons deal to
the Chechens. Right. And this was like,
whatever, 15 years ago, and here,
this guy's living this quiet life in the Ukraine, working for the power company.
And 12 years later, they come and get them. I mean,
you look at the case of a scalpel, you know,
the guy that they poisoned with Nova chalk a few years in Saulsbury,
that was another case where, you know, the guy had that was in England, right?
Yeah. That was in England. The guy had been, you know, out of sight,
out of mind for, uh, for, for 15 years. Um,
you look at even the poisoning of Alexandra with an ankle in 2006. Well,
at the time that they actually poisoned with the Neko with, with polonium,
he had already been living in London for like seven or eight
years. He had, he had fled to the UK that long ago.
So the whole piece that the Michael shorts had wrote, uh,
and put forward in the New York times was essentially that, you know,
they don't forget. And there's just, and there's just,
you know, a list. And when they feel that they can strike,
uh, uh, they do.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.